it's a sorry sight the pitch at the
Maracana stadium has seen better days
it's not only a legendary Olympic venue
it was on this once hallowed turf where
Mario götze shot the goal that sealed
Germany's victory over Argentina at the
last Soccer World Cup final there's only
one word fit to describe the Marikana
legendary the stadium hosted two World
Cup finals and last year the curtain
fell on the Olympic Games here in a
place of pomp and ceremony it's hard to
look at the proud arena now no more than
a shadow of its former self the 400
million euros stadium has gone dark the
powers been cut and no one wants to pay
the electricity bill a stadium official
takes us through the empty halls they
take your food this is where the Olympic
organizers offices were both under queue
we're missing screens over there the
turnstiles are gone you really can't run
a stadium without them the Olympic
coordinators left the stadium in such
bad shape that its operators refused to
assume responsibility for maintaining
the premises where these chairs belong
is anyone's guess as is what's missing
or since when there's never been an
official handover now the case has gone
to court and it seems none of the
parties want anything to do with the
stadium meanwhile the bills are piling
up what semis were optimizing maybe it
would be cheaper to renovate the stadium
but that would be breaking the contracts
as the stadium's owner the state of Rio
along with the Olympic Committee must
come to an agreement on its future only
then will we see investment and the
bills getting today while the situation
remains unresolved the Maracana remains
closed leaving the roughly 4,000 people
who used to come each day stuck outside
it's such a shame we should be having
fun in there they pumped so much money
into that Stadium it's
that they have no tours friendlies or
regular league matches I don't get it
this bar across the street is fighting
for survival games are sometimes played
in the Maracana but not more than one
per week for the bars few customers
there's just one topic of conversation
first they let the public pay the huge
price tag then they simply close the
doors that's not right we paid for this
Stadium with our taxes wasn't cheap
we're still paying it off we have a lot
of problems in the city this wallet
stadium is simply a microcosm of the
bigger crisis we're facing in Rio the
stadium's fortunes may be shifting to
interested parties want to take over the
contract and get the Maracana back in
shape so perhaps this gloomy phase is
just a sad chapter in a bigger story
that will have a happier ending few
Brazilians see their countries bigger
crises in the same way